the coronaviruses the worldwide outbreak
has reached nearly 100,000 confirmed
cases in more than 33 hundred deaths
health officials in the US and elsewhere
are now scrambling to contain it there
are now at least 230 known cases in 21
US states Nevada and Colorado reported
their first cases yesterday at least 12
people have died eleven of them in
Washington state where Seattle suburb
has closed all schools for the next two
weeks this morning a cruise ship with
passengers and crew members suspected of
having the disease sits 70 miles off the
coast of San Francisco that city just
reported its first cases Jamie yuccas is
in San Francisco Jamie our repast
endures on that ship responding well
Anthony we spoke with a few passengers
who aren't necessarily scared but we're
concerned with the ship's protocols
California health officials say 35
people from the ship developed flu-like
symptoms during the trip and will keep
the passengers off shore to ensure the
safety of people in California with more
than 3,500 passengers and crew stranded
onboard the Grand Princess Cruise the
Coast Guard rushed to the scene dropping
under the ship's deserted deck 300 test
kits to potentially infected passengers
well everybody on board the cruise ship
be tested or just a certain select
number of people the CDC is will select
who is be tested but we they are testing
folks who are symptomatic first those
tests were then sent to this lab in
Richmond California and results are
expected this morning this ship will
stay about 70 miles offshore until those
on board are deemed healthy we spoke
with Chris Grady who is currently on
board the princess cruise he says the
ship allowed people to roam around
common areas even though this very same
ship carried a passenger who died of
coronavirus on Wednesday I felt like
they probably should have just had
everybody go to their rooms pretty much
immediately once they figure that out up
the coast in Washington State the 12th
US death was announced eight are
connected to this nursing home in
when my mother I got a phone call this
morning that she passed at 3:30 in the
morning Pat Herrick says she was told
her mother Elaine died of natural causes
she praised the staff but says her
mother was healthy and Herrick wants
answers I'm asking and lobbying to make
sure she gets tested I want her body
tested and I've been told well we don't
do that you know we just have to assume
that it's natural causes and so I'm
saying that's not okay
I think somebody somewhere decided that
this population that people wasn't worth
using wasn't worth wasting resources on
Kevin Connolly's father-in-law is also
living at life care he told our Carter
Evans that he's demanding government
intervention there is no quarantine
there is no process it's getting worse
it's not getting better
Princess Cruises has already cancelled
its upcoming voyage on this ship as it
deals with the crisis health officials
here have not said when they expect
passengers to be let off the ship but it
is expected to take days
one passenger told us they are being
told to stay in their rooms for now Tony
a lot of anxious people Jamie thank you
very much